Awesome.
So you wanted to chat about OB meds for the Inplex.
Is that correct?
No, OB in general and then just any med stuff that you can suggest.
Cool. And then where where you look at it?
You're in Australia?
Yeah.
And you're taking the Inplex like as reciprocity to come to the US or something like that?
Yeah, exactly. So I'm booked in for the 25th.
Okay.
And then I'll be moving to Colorado as soon as my visa comes through.
So hopefully in the next month or two.
Oh, nice. Solid choice. I mean, it's not New Mexico, but it's good.
Yeah.
Thanks, dude. Sweet.
How long have you been a nurse for?
About eight years.
Sweet. Cool.
So mostly ED and then military.
So some primary health, some aviation, some air retrieval stuff.
What will you be doing in Colorado? Do you know yet?
Or are you just coming out here first and then we'll find a shot.
Yeah. Hopefully I'll get it. One of the big trauma EDs.
Okay.
University of Colorado or something like that.
Nice.
Sweet man.
But I'll just go to get through this Inplex exam, which is throwing me a bit.
Yeah. Have you, will this be your first time taking it?
Yeah.
Okay. And then what have you been using for studying in general?
I got.
This one.
Okay. Right on. Yeah.
I think that I'm just in general, like a good way to go.
Test prep in general is just getting a bank of like practice questions.
Yep. Yeah.
So I've just been working through those and then.
I get them right. Or I just write down.
The rationale and trying to get my head around it.
Sweet.
Cool.
Well, we can definitely go through some OB stuff. I mean,
I have to admit it's not my area of expertise, but this is good for me.
It's good for me to.
As well.
Let me see if I can.
Share a screen here.
Yeah.
Okay. Sweet. So.
I guess my understanding before, which maybe was not totally accurate was.
That you wanted to go over specific medications, but regardless,
I think this is like a good starting point to go over.
Yep.
Just things in general.
So I have an old pharmacology book from nursery school when I did my BSN.
And I just went through the chapters on.
The
BSN.
And then I went through and like just highlighted or made bold.
A couple of things that I think.
Are more high yield than the others.
Like a lot of these, we don't really need to know for the influx.
I mean, I guess maybe don't hold me to that.
It's been quite a long time since.
Specifically studied for that test.
There's some things that I think will commonly come up.
I don't think they will likely get into.
Like the emergent stuff that you're mostly familiar with.
I think there's a lot of other things that I think are really.
You know,
I think that's a really good idea to, you know,
Yeah, just review some basic like physiology and bath of physiology
stuff, I guess.
Yep.
So cool. I guess when you just like work through this list and like,
whatever questions we come up with along the way,
then we can identify them. And then I, I have my textbook.
And I think that's a really good idea.
I think that's a really good idea.
I think it's like fairly high yield to talk about both like iron
supplementation.
And full of acid.
Be.
Like included in like your stand old prenatal vitamin.
The idea behind the first sofade is that you can get anemia with.
Pregnancy. If you're not supplementing.
It's a really good idea.
And then you can have a lot of
Pregnancy.
And that I think increases throughout pregnancy.
So like the most need for iron supplementation would be in the third
trimester of products delivery.
When you get like the most increase in size.
And that sort of checks out like, you know,
what's the only thing I can do to get the best results.
And that's kind of like the most common.
And I think that's one of the things that we can do in pregnancy.
And I think that's, that's, that's, that's, that's,
that's pretty easy to understand.
And then with full of acid, the concern there is that you can have.
Problems with like fetal development.
So I think spina bifida is the most common complication that comes up in
the testing environment.
So that would be the one to keep an eye on.
And then with the iron supplementation.
It's likely going to be for an EBS.
Cool.
Yeah.
Sweet.
Any questions on those ones?
No, they're pretty, pretty straightforward.
Okay. Yeah. The other ones here.
Are just mentioning things about like different treatments for nausea and
vomiting, just like symptoms of.
Being pregnant in general.
I don't think.
Okay.
I think they said it was really good.
Like, I don't know.
Any of these medications.
Like specifically for OB, but like.
The Inclex can test you on all kinds of medications.
And the thing is that they tend to focus on our little different than
what we focus on in the pre hospital setting or in the emergency
setting.
That was like one thing that I struggled with the nursing school is that
I wanted to learn like the indication in the dose.
Right. But on the nursing side.
looking for you to be familiar with like what the medication is used for and concerns with
like with delivery. So are you taking it with food or are there concerns of the medications?
Don't necessarily have to know the specifics, you just need to know that those are things to
reference. Yeah and that's I'm struggling with that a bit. Yeah I mean that was really tough
for me. I remember like the worst grade I got in nursing school when I first went through was
in pharmacology because I mean I had all my doses memorized because I thought that's what
we needed to memorize but not the case. So I don't think like I don't think any of these
are particularly high yield. Just looking through this list here. Yeah. Yeah I wouldn't worry about
the specifics on these other than just knowing that like if you see any of these and the likely
reason is going to be for nausea. Yeah I mean if you have tons of time and you want to look into
the specifics to any of these I think you maybe could but I wouldn't worry about getting into
the details on any of this stuff. Yeah. Same thing with these ones that are available over the counter.
The brand names here may be different than what you're familiar with but I got the generic ones
there as well. Yeah I wouldn't focus too much on those symptoms. The general ones would be your iron
supplementation and then your folic acid. I do think however scrolling down here that your
tocolytics are always testable both in the emergency setting like whenever getting into
specific certifications but also in for the NCLEX. So knowing that the two primary tocolytics that
come up on the nursing side will be tributyline and naxulfate. I don't think you need to know
like the specific doses for those but knowing like the drug classes is likely something that
could be tested and they're listed there for and I can send this document to you afterwards. You
don't have to you don't have to write it. I'm happy to make sure you know. So yeah I think it's worth
I think it's worth knowing both of those. The concerns with those medications so
the main one that may get testable that like seems to always come up is if you're giving
magsulfate that can cause respiratory depression. The normal way everyone says that we're supposed to
like assess for progression towards respiratory depression will be checking deep tendon reflexes.
In practice like at least in the transport and emergency setting we don't often do that.
We have better tools to observe that like entitled CO2 monitoring like waveform catenography.
But the fix would be if you gave too much mag or give it too fast and had problems so you had a
patient stop breathing you could fix that by giving calcium so calcium and glucoma and calcium
chloride. So that's that's worth knowing as well. And then because of that anytime we're giving
magnesium magnesium we want to give it slowly. So like you know in a non-emergent setting like
we're talking about in OB we're going to give that like fastest over 10 minutes but likely over
you know 20 or 30 minutes. Yep.
The next one here is and the order these are just the way they happen to be presented in the book.
There's nothing special about this order. For surfactant development in the fetus so if you
have a baby who's looking to be born preterm the concern is that the lungs may not be fully
developed. So the primary treatment for that would be beta-methasone or celestone.
So that's something that frequently comes up on test. You'll sometimes see like in a couple of
the books I have lying around here you'll see that dexamethasone or decadron is mentioned as
an alternative. But I don't know I like I don't work in OB so I don't know how frequently that
is used but I do see I have seen on test before that the beta-methasone question comes up frequently.
So yeah that's something to keep in mind. Yep. And then the next one that I think is particularly
high yield it will be like the complications. And it was listed in the textbook I have under
preeclampsia but I think it's worth reviewing in general like the whole spectrum from pregnancy
induced hypertension to preeclampsia and potentially clampsia and then to help syndrome.
So that's something you haven't reviewed in a while. I would definitely just kind of brush up on that.
But I guess if we start at the beginning so pregnancy induced hypertension is you know
basically as it sounds so somebody's at baseline before they get pregnant they have a blood pressure
what would be considered normal and then after they get pregnant they develop hypertension.
And that typically will resolve after delivery of the baby. But the concern is that if mom is
markedly tact or not tachycardic hypertensive while she's carrying the baby that can
put us at higher risk for certain complications. So we want to treat that during pregnancy.
I've actually got I pulled up a paper on that just for my own reference to review but I can
send that to you as well about you know this general progression for pregnancy
induced hypertension all the different agents we use. The next step I guess in the progression
would be preeclampsia where we're worried about the mom going into a clampsia or having seizures.
And that's where these medications that are listed here come into play.
So if we're on the hypertensive side but we're like in this preeclampsia realm and we
acutely want to drop blood pressure we often go to these two hydrolyzine or labetalone those ones
are in bold and it kind of depends on like what protocols you're working under and what
reference you're looking at which is first line which is second. But those two are commonly used
for preeclampsia. You sometimes will see magnesium given like for somebody who is quite prone to
having seizures to going into a clampsia but it's definitely the treatment of choice when
we actually are aclantic. So once the mom is having seizures we want to get magnesium first.
So I don't think that the Inplex would ask you like specifics about any of these. I don't think
they would test you on specific doses or like specific drug types for these but I do think
it's fair game for them to ask you about which of these potentially is a treatment for the
periclantic patient or for the eclamptivi. And then on the far end of the spectrum would be
help syndrome. So that's when you have elevated liver enzymes and low platelets and those would
be the two testable things. So like maybe you would have a question like your patient presents with
she's she's undergoing treatment for pregnancy use hypertension.
Routine lab work shows either or both elevated LFTs or low platelets what's going on with the
patient. I don't think they would specifically ask you about you know treatments but I think
just being able to identify that that's what's going on. It's something that might come up.
The next thing I have on my list here which is about induction of labor. I don't think any of
this stuff is particularly high yield but I think it's worth just like being familiar with
these medications and knowing what they're used for. But aside from that the only one that you
may see is oxytocin with like postpartum hemorrhage or something like that. But in general like at the
entry level for nurses we're not this is stuff you're going to learn when you like if you go into OB.
But I guess it is it is fair game for testing at least at the superficial level.
Yeah. So the next one here is there's a section in my book about postpartum promotion of bowel
function. And these are all things that I think are testable not specifically for OB but just in
general. There are medications that get used a lot in the in a hospital setting for inpatient
nursing. So just being where being familiar with your stool softeners and your laxatives I think
makes sense going into the NCLEX. I wouldn't spend a lot of time I think just like knowing the names
and knowing that they are like stool softeners and laxators. I don't even think you need to be able
to differentiate which ones are stool softeners and which ones are laxatives. Just in general those
are ones to promote bowel function or to avoid constipation I think are worth doing.
And the next one here that I think maybe is worth reviewing as well is things that are given
after birth given to the neonate after birth. I guess this first one primary concern is actually
to mom but regardless. So it's worth knowing that Rogam I don't know if it's got the same like
brand name where you are but it's the it's the first one that I think is worth reviewing.
Like when we're talking about blood types and for saying someone's like positive or negative
the Rh factor is the is what we're actually looking at. And if we have a like a Rh negative mom
who is exposed to Rh positive blood the concern there is she can build up
like a iso immunization against that Rh positive sign. So in the future like if she
in the future were to get pregnant again with a Rh positive baby it could spontaneously abort.
So we want to avoid that. So we give this immune globulin to Rh negative moms who are potentially
exposed to Rh or who are exposed to Rh positive blood to prevent that from happening. So the
the case that is specific to OB is Rh negative mom carries Rh positive blood and something happens
during delivery where mom is potentially exposed to baby's blood. So like I'd have to double check
this but I think like the for sure things would be like a c-section. Well I guess maybe not. I don't
have to look that one up but like if there's a delivery where there's potential I don't know I
guess I need to look up the specifics of when that would be like a vaginal delivery with complications
where blood could cross. I don't know in a day if there's any PV blading we'll give it. Yeah I think
that I guess a c-section would probably be contained unless there's some kind of like
trauma to the baby. So I think a c-section would be pretty safe but a vaginal delivery with any
bleeding I think would be a case to give Rhogram. And then the other situation that you're probably
familiar with is like blood transfusion. So if you have like a woman of childbearing age and we give
her positive blood but she's negative then they're broken as well. So cool and the next two are just
vaccines they're given after birth. I don't think that the vaccines are like a high yield thing on
the NCLEX but they may ask just in general like as far as like coming up with a care plan for a baby
after delivery what some consider one of those would be vaccinations. I don't think they would
test you specifically on which ones and like timelines and things like that. And then the next
two here I also don't think are super high yield on the NCLEX but one would be like optomethymic
ointment if we're worried about any infection during delivery and then vitamin K if we are
short on our clotting factors if there's like some kind of concern for anemia. But I don't think
either those would be particularly high yield. But if they are it's going to be referred it's
like going to be in the context of like things to do for the baby after delivery. So if you just
remember that like that always reminds an ointment and giving vitamin K like that's the situation I
think you'd probably be able to answer that question just fine. And then some other sections
that were mentioned in this textbook I have that I don't think you need to focus on at all
would be medications for pain relief during labor. Like that's not something I don't I think knowing
your pain medications in general is something that's testable but I don't know about specific
four OB things. And same thing with like anesthetic agents for delivery like I don't I don't think
they would test on that. And the last one would be like surfactant therapy in the neonate. I think
all of those are pretty niche and the infant is more for like it's more of a it is an entry level
exam. So they're not looking to get into the nitty gritty detail on that sort of thing.
Yeah. So I don't know I don't know if that was useful for you or if there's any specific
questions you have on these. There's anything you want to dive into a little more.
Could we go over and if you've sort of got your head around it some of the
OBE sort of emergencies your percent of previous percent are abrupt. Yeah. Okay. That's a fair
point. So. Abruption will start there. That's when the where the placenta attaches to the uterus.
It starts to tear away and that can cause bleeding in whatever space is left there.
I think having a having a visual to see how that one looks is definitely helpful for understanding
the physiology there. But things that can cause that to happen because there's like a lot of
small vessels there like it's quite dense in terms of like microvasculature things like hypertension
can put you at risk for that because you can cause that you know you can cause those
tears to happen or that vasculature to break down. You can also see with trauma.
I think the key like diagnostic would be. Yeah. I think I don't think you would see
external bleeding with the corruption routinely unless you also like unless it ruptured somehow
or so like normally that bleeding would be contained in that space. If you do see bleeding
I think the textbook way of describing it would be dark red because it sat there for a while.
Now in reality I don't I don't know how often that actually happens but that's like the
the textbook description of so like you know the dark red bleeding. Whereas placenta
preview I think they describe that as like bright red bleeding. Okay. But in real life like I don't
I don't know how easy it is to make that distinction between the two. I don't know that's what the books
say I guess so it's likely it's testable. And then previous when you have the placenta
attaches to the uterine wall over top of the the vaginal opening. So
during pregnancy is not so much an issue because like everything develops just fine.
But as you progress to delivery and you start to you start to dilate in a phase
that area opens up and then you might see that bright red bleeding.
I don't know if that description makes sense but it definitely helps to look at pictures for those
two to understand like the difference in the physiology. So with uh abruption you basically
have like some kind of tearing away of the placenta from the uterine wall. Kind of like
if you were looking at like a balloon like here and here's like the opening where the baby's coming
it's somewhere like in the balloon part. Whereas in previa like this part starts out when my thumbs
are they start out slow and as it starts to open up that's when you start to see bleeding.
Treatment for those is mostly like supportive and like resuscitation based.
So it's not like you're going to do something to prevent either of those processes from happening.
In the case of placenta previa depending on like how like I don't know like if here's your
we're going back to this analogy here like if this is your opening here where my thumbs are.
If you're like smack dab in the middle that baby's likely going to need a c-section or like the
bleeding is going to be quite severe and you know mom may exalinate. If it's just like a little bit
of overlap like if I'm implanted here like just a smidge I may get some of that bright red bleeding
with delivery and it may be totally fine. So it lives on a spectrum from where it like maybe
totally okay and it may be quite severe. And then with abruption it also depends on like how much
blood is released like how big that abruption is. Again this is not like my area of expertise but
I imagine that it's there are likely some eruptions that are quite small that nobody knows about until
after the placenta is delivered maybe you see some like I don't know like some kind of clot on
the placenta maybe. But I don't know that for sure that's something that I would have to ask
somebody who works in that setting. But yeah those are the two big ones as far as like bleeding goes.
The other one which we talk about more in the ER and transport setting would be a uterine rupture.
And that's yeah when that that uterine that contain that uterus that container that's
incubating the fetus when that gets injured normally it's like a traumatic injury to
to mother's belly like a blood force trauma or something like that. When it ruptures and all the
fluid contained like it's no longer able to like maintain its shape and the telltale sign of that
is you're able to palpate fetal parts by palpating the mother's abdomen. So that's like the
that's the keyword trigger for like the testing setting. Although I'm not sure how often that
comes up on the inplex but for sure in like your CEN or your I don't know CFRN, FPC type thing,
that's the telltale sign. I don't know specifics on it but mortality is quite high for
the fetus with a uterine rupture and like that will likely have to be a
a c-section delivery to salvage that situation. Yeah I mean I guess there's a
yeah yeah I can't I guess I was gonna say maybe there's a case where I don't know mom and dad are
like on the way to the hospital after mom's water broke and they get a car wreck and I have a
uterine rupture and maybe the baby can be delivered but that that wouldn't happen because
you need the contractions right you need the force of that uterus pushing the baby out so that's for
sure gonna have to be a c-section. So I just had to explain that one out loud to myself I think.
I'll do the same thing. So I think those are the three big ones I guess leading up to delivery.
The other big complication would be postpartum hemorrhage. Again that's not something I think
that comes up often on the NCLEX but for sure comes up on those other other exams. So our
main treatments there are resuscitation with like a couple extra things. So we can we can do all the
things you know like we're getting away from fluid resuscitation so blood would be ideal.
You can give TXA in these situations. Oxytocin to help force that uterus to contract combined
with doing a fundamental massage. Like in a testing environment you just have to know
like fundamental massage and that's all they're looking for. In a practical setting just know
that it's like quite an aggressive thing so you really have to get in there and put quite a lot
of effort into that. It's not just like putting your hand on the belly and like you know giving
it like a Buddha belly rub. It's quite an aggressive thing. Yeah there's quite a lot
into isn't it all surprised how far you've really got to push into find it. For sure.
The other thing that sometimes comes up and I this is one of the things that I have no idea how
often this actually happens in practice is in the you sometimes will hear reference to people
like putting something inside and like using that as like fill that space inside the uterus and then
like fundamental massaging around it to kind of pack it in. Yeah like leaving that in there.
I've heard it mentioned like pre-hospitaly and like emergently that you can like do that with
a fist and someone just like rides the receiving facility with their like fist inside. I've also
seen it in classes where people mention using a Foley and like inflating the balloon like in
excess so it's quite big so putting the Foley in and then inflating it and then doing your fundamental
massage around that. That said that's one of those things that like I don't actually know how often
that actually happens. I have a feeling that like it's quite rare but I don't know like maybe it's
one of those like last ditch efforts if you're like in a rural setting and you don't know what to do.
Yeah for sure. Do that until you can get to surgery. Yeah.
Yeah the first time I came across that there's a series of courses called like the one for
babies is called helping babies breathe and the one for mothers is called helping mothers survive.
I think it's I think it was put together by the same group that does like neonatal resuscitation
program but these courses are designed to teach in the developing world like the helping babies
breathe one is geared to people who like work in a healthcare setting but like may not be like licensed
or whatever they like like you know maybe they're like working in like a delivery and like a mom baby
unit they just like help do deliveries inspect the baby and wake them up. It was like to teach basic
resuscitation so like a BLS version I guess you could describe it as of neonatal resuscitation
and then they have a subsequent class that's for same idea but for helping mothers survive and
that's why I first come across that I've since seen it in like in other courses but again like I
think that is in reality likely reserved for those types of settings or somewhere where you
can ask you. Yeah I came across I did a rural and remote for those that are way out in the middle of
nowhere without a doctor and dealing with it on their own and yeah they said it and my sister's
a midwife she said she's done it a couple of times in some more rural hospitals where they've got to
call the surgeons so yeah by manual compression while they sit and wait for the surgeon to finish
his golf game and get to the hospital. Yeah that's fair so she's doing it pretty like with a hand so
yeah I think that's far more common the Foley thing I'm not sure about that one. Yeah I hadn't
heard of that one before so cool yeah that would be nuts but I mean I guess I mean it's same idea
with like your like in a trauma center if you have like a a gnarly trauma come in where you
have something like in the box you're gonna crack the chest and just put a Foley in any hole
so they're versatile tools it's worth keeping in your bad eyes. Yeah okay so postpartum hemorrhage
we can do all our normal resuscitation things plus oxytocin and fungal massage and maybe do
like bi-manual compression or the Foley trick. Yeah I think the only other thing that sometimes
comes up along those lines is if mom is able to breastfeed that can stimulate some endogenous
release of oxytocin but that said I think if you had like a genuine resuscitation that you're
working on a postpartum mom that's probably not something that we would take the time to do but
it comes up in a testing environment so you can hear that. Yeah one other thing that's
more of like a discussion is I know the way we typically teach giving oxytocin is you can
either give it as a IM dose or you can put it in a liter bag and give it slowly but that said like
I'm not entirely sure the reasoning behind giving it IV slowly like I don't know enough to say
for sure like why we don't just give the IV dose as a push and yeah I've seen it done before and
like a really bad like postpartum hemorrhage by another provider and like I don't know it seemed
to work like mom survives but I don't know I don't know why we teach to give it either IM
or IV over time versus just giving it IV directly that might be something that I can
yeah I'll have to look that one up and I'll send you a follow-up email or something.
But all those details that's not stuff that I think would come up on the
NCLEX for sure. Yeah I guess I think that's let me think so we talked about
abruption placenta previa uterine rupture postpartum hemorrhage the other emergency would be a
clampsia and we talked about that a little bit earlier so our fix for that would be to give
magnesium sulfate we don't want to slam it we don't give it fast but we can you know
drip it in over 10 minutes and then our concern when we give mag sulfate is that we can cause
respiratory depression so the textbook or the test will want you to say that we're checking for
deep tendon reflexes in reality in most settings I think we're just assessing like a waveform
capnography and if we see evidence of respiratory depression then we can and we can make decisions
then and then if we gave way too much and the patient stops breathing the fix for that would be
calcium. Yep. The other emergent things that I think maybe do come up on the NCLEX and I think
I had a couple notes on that previous list would be like preterm labor so it's not necessarily
like always an emergency but if you have a situation where you want to delay the delivery
of the baby for whatever reason let's say you're in a small hospital and you want to get them to
a big hospital or we're in the field and we want to get them there or you know the baby's like
preterm then yeah the the medications for that would be the class we prefer to as tocolytics
so terbutylene is like the most common one we can also use mag sulfate
yeah I think those are those are the two that generally come up on on testing there's a couple
other on that list that are used more I think in a hospital setting but like in the field or like
emergently like those are the two we'd use. Yeah, terbutylene and that.
I think that's all the emergency things. The other thing that
doesn't really matter so much for the NCLEX that is like worth looking at for give me a second to
I'm going to pull this up and screen share it with you
see if I can find it
okay so let me share my screen again with you and we'll pull this up
can you can you see it there yep okay so this is a book a textbook that you can just
find for free online and I'll send you a link to it as well but this program is called the
Alarm International Program and they have this mnemonic for dealing with like complicated
delivery and let me just scroll down and we'll pull it up here
okay so this is the mnemonic here and we don't have to like read every step but it's basically
like a way like if you had a baby who you're trying to deliver and it's not delivering
like things you can do to help facilitate that delivery like in reality like if I tomorrow at
work when I go back on shift if I had a complicated delivery like in the middle of nowhere like
New Mexico or West Texas and I had to deal with some kind of like complicated delivery like this
is something that like I don't have memorized I've never worked in this setting but I always keep on
me like I'll send you a reference card actually I'll send you a link to this and also like the
reference card that I use that has this mnemonic and pictures of all of these maneuvers so that
in that setting I can just pull it out and put it right next to us and we'll just work with them one
at a time some of the things like you probably don't have the autonomy to do in most clinical
settings like like you and I like doing a peak anatomy but this mnemonic was designed to be
universal for all providers so we don't have to like go over like all the specifics of this but
like this textbook is awesome it was just like available for free online there's pictures of
all of the maneuvers as well as discussions these things aren't tested on the Inplex
but some of these maneuvers do come up on your
FPC and CFRN type tests like if you're interested in getting into transport whenever you do get
over here to the US so a lot of these maneuvers do come up so this is an awesome reference for
just like reviewing that kind of stuff before you go into a testing environment and like I said I
made these I parsed out all these images and kind of made a little quick reference guy that I carry
on me at work but yeah that's the other complication you may come across in like OB would be like a
complicated delivery that's I don't think this is something you'd see on the Inplex but it's just
yeah it's good to know and I think just knowing where to find a reference like that is super
important because in the in the absence of like time working in that setting I don't think it's
basic to expect that most of us would be able to to perform those kind of things without some kind
of reference so just you just don't say enough emergencies do you even if you've done a bit of
training and yeah and delivering yeah realistically like I mean like humans and all mammals in general
have been like giving birth for you know thousands of thousands of years and they almost always go
just fine so the incidence of like some kind of difficulty with delivery is is quite rare
and then the incidence of a delivery that's complicated where they didn't know about it
ahead of time and like made plans to accommodate that are even rare I think it's different if
you're working you know like in a total of something yeah yeah like but in general like
yeah the chances of us seeing that sort of thing with the frequency to build some level of like
confidence in those skills is just it's not going to happen unless you take time to go specifically
work in that field so yeah having having access to those references I think is super good
okay so let's just do a quick mental review of the complication just to make sure we got them all
so we talked about um eruption placenta previa uterine rupture postpartum hemorrhage
clampsia and we also just alluded to the idea of like that it lives on a spectrum with pregnancy
induced hypertension all that to help syndrome and then complications of delivery I think that's
yeah I think that's most everything
yeah am I missing anything no that's sort of my mental run through that I've been working with
that seems to be the big ones yeah then you'll have to say there's some general prey and post
care stuff but that's that's not too bad that's sort of general nursing I can deal with that
right yeah and I don't I was actually looking before we got on the call like some tests do like a
do offer outlines like for like specific testable items and there is stuff for the
inplex but it's not that detailed um whereas like for our certification tests like you know
two we talk about all the time here um in our setting is the CFRN like your flight nurse one
and then your FPC your flight paramedic one those ones have like pretty good outlines of like
specific things that they're going to test on and there's all kinds of like materials specific to
that um in the nursing side like for the inplex specifically a lot of that stuff lives behind a
paywall so it's like proprietary stuff um that said you you've already purchased a review book so
they likely have an outline it's not like in your book itself it like maybe on their like online
content yep and they might have a better a little better guidance than I do about specific things
that may or may not be tested on um so even if it doesn't come direct from like inplex itself
um like all these testing agencies they you know they build their review material built on like
all kinds of feedback over years and years and years of this with like lots and lots of students
so even if it's not like officially sanctioned it's I think it's pretty good yep so yeah as far
as like figuring out like from the stuff we talked about and what's on that list um what is for sure
testable and what's not like I would have to like defer you to someone else on that
yep no that's okay any other sort of common meds on um interaction type stuff you think
is the the high points yeah I don't I know they're not super big on doses um
I vaguely remember getting some questions on like
like interactions and like when meds should be administered but I don't think
I don't know maybe that's like a holdover memory from when I like missed all those questions in
pharmacology when I was in nursing school like I don't it seems weird to me like thinking back on
it that those would be tested on the inplex because they have so many other things that are more
important um so yeah I I think probably your best bet if you're like for time spent would be if you
have a review book that just has things of questions just to focus on that especially if
they have like little short narratives about why you got the question wrong um yeah am I done
which is yeah I think that kind of prep is is quite high yield for like the time spent on it
um yeah I wouldn't like I wouldn't take the time to like make no cards for all the drugs you can
think of all the drugs that come up in your like pharmacology book from nursing school
because I think that just takes a lot of time and takes away from things that are probably
more high yield on the test so I think the next strategy would be to focus on questions and then
during those questions if you notice a medication come up um maybe just like pull out a drug
reference guide and look up like just you know quiz yourself the next couple days on you know
like drug class mechanism indications and any like significant complications or drug interactions
but I wouldn't I don't think you need to get into heavy detail on any of those yep
yeah awesome sweet man well thanks very much that was really helpful yeah for sure um yeah
I'll send you um I can send you a copy of this video whenever it saves and also that uh a link
to that I had that paper that I talked about about like pregnancy news hypertension and different
treatments and then this reference for that alarminemonic and also like the little reference
card that I made and used um so yeah I'll send that stuff your way and then um yeah if you have
any questions let me know um if you make it to Colorado decide you want to live somewhere with
less people New Mexico is always recruiting yeah yeah well um I've been there before my wife's
good friends uh from from Albuquerque so I've been down there and get down there every once in a while
right now yeah I was pretty amazed how different it is from Colorado when it's really not that far
away yeah it's super close um I mean Colorado is awesome this whole region is awesome
everything in the southwest yeah I think I'm I'm a lifer so yeah I uh I just love being signing
the mountains in Denver they just being able to look out and see them all the time yeah well
right on man um yeah let us know if you ever have uh any other questions or want to review and
do let us know how the intellect goes yeah I will thank you very much I really appreciate it it's
been very helpful awesome all right we'll take care and I'll see ya thanks yeah